[Music]
earlier today one of our writers saw
something on the internet that bothered
him and uh he'd like to discuss it on
the show so please welcome good friend
of ours let's get him out here mr dion
cole
thanks conan so i was surfing the
internet when i stumbled across this
training video for that furniture store
pier one imports take a look
[Music]
customer engagement is the heart of the
plan that's why i'm a left coaching fan
let's connect yeah
[Music]
imports
whose idea was it to have this corny ass
black man rhyming about making some
sales with a bunch of lame ass white
people dancing behind him
huh and first of all who going to
believe that a black man was in pier one
anyway
pier one you should be ashamed and to
the black dude that's in the video you
should be ashamed of yourself too for
doing something so belittling
yeah okay dion didn't you do a training
video for the container store just two
years ago
selling a container can be a my greener
but after i explain it it'll be a
no-brainer just say hello there hello
put yourself in my box put it in there
hello
if they want to create a tub or a basket
get up in the grill make the customer
ask for it wow with the shoe rack
shoving the can stacks throwing sweaters
under your bed that's so whack
don't put it over there yes hello there
put your stuff in my box or put in my
box
[Applause]
dion cole everybody i'm sorry
[Music]